there are no shortcuts to anything you  can't cram for a competition you can't  fake Readiness in order to be present  in order to be able to execute to the  best of your ability I cannot over  emphasize the importance of preparation  like if you're an actor you you can't  just memorize the lines they have to  become so rude that you forget them and  you can show up and be present for the  performance but I think what you see are  a lot of people like faking the  preparation part and trying to kind of  get through certain experiences and play  it off as if they had prepared but you  know you can always tell if you didn't  really put the preparation in and you  kind of get away with it even if you get  the good result you're not getting that  feeling you're not getting that enriched  experience that you would have had you  put yourself on the line and tried your  hardest which means investing in that  preparation piece